hey guys Ryan writes in the hizzy hi
we're gonna check out today kmpl rap
album confessions we just watch one of
the most depressing [ __ ] videos
darkest things I've ever experienced
five creepiest calls and so yeah this
better cheer us the [ __ ] up I really
hope it's funny
[Music]
first things first
I do not care that you're a
multi-platinum selling rapper gun rack
what I care about is that i 100% know
that you murdered Darnell Simmons so you
better start talking
yeah but you want God you know I'm
actually I'm very glad that you said
that because I respectfully I beg to
differ
[Music]
[Music]
imagine my birthday party where last
November 9 at Red Lobster
mm-hmm geez I gotta tell you good right
I find that really hard to believe just
confess correct
confess that shellfish is the only thing
their eyes would tell this
now as it is they just happen to be in
adult water but identify it who would
call it a gun of the long-ass variety
some seaweed in there to look the tiger
I hate to break it to you I am horny
punch in real slow when I'm lying devil
guy the name of the album is I killed
Darnell Simmons
so concept over kaiser that's a picture
of you a picture of you
[Laughter]
you're going away for a long time he's
free to go
what no way no no no we have everything
we need you know some of the girlfriend
she just confessed to the whole thing
infidelity crime of passion
let's go mr. rack greedy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we didn't necessarily completely
succeed I mean that was so pretty Midori
pretty dark it's still pretty dark I
appreciate their dark humor though
they're just really I think those two I
love how they took the concept of rap
artists how they're so bold about like
being criminals and Sunday and and
really amplifying it yeah but they play
it off those words it's so funny man
almost completely like half the glass is
half-full glass is half-full I feel a
little bit better than I did before yeah
a little bit a little bit anyway if you
guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Selena's channel color my
energy I'll be performing their lives
September 5th check it out and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine periscope she had snapchat too
Mayson hats key hey man I've been
watching you for a while and [ __ ]
funny and I would love to get a shout
out there they sent a meme of one of the
Olsen twins from Full House saying don't
worry be happy listening to it oh that's
really sweet of you to do Mason you're
great stand-up guy you're a stand-up guy
Mason I want to hack you up like Jason I
want to eat you up like raisins I want
to make love to you like Malaysians yeah
that'd be nice huh
what's your last name Husky I feel
really happy I feel so gladly happy so
sadly that I'm thinking about the
darkness inside of me because of a
[ __ ] video that people requested
taking my feelings having it be tested
now all I want to do is be well-rested
wake up out of this grave so I can
behave like I got a smile on my face I
don't know what's going on right